- Are you rolling, Jimmy?
- What does my hair look like?
- Yep.
Where is makeup and hair, by the way?
[laughter]
[upbeat music]
"Long Way Up" is the third part
of our motorcycle adventures,
Charley Boorman and I.
- We've done "Round,"
and we've done "Down,"
and now we were looking to do "Up."
- We decided to go from the very bottom
of South America
up to Los Angeles.
It's a really long way up, this one.
Charley and I met on a movie.
We both had very small babies,
and we're both madly into motorbikes.
And so the sort of combination
of those two things
made us very fast friends.
- [laughs]
- All right.
She's alive.
We complement each other really well.
If I'm down,
he tends to sort of pull me up
and vice versa.
- And Ewan moved over to the states,
and our paths separated for a while.
About 2016, got clipped by a car,
smashed my legs up to pieces,
and it took me a couple of years
to walk again properly.
I wanted to get myself better enough
to get back on the motorbike.
- Our adventures,
it's what makes him feel alive.
- The chemistry that those two guys
have is--
you know, you can't create that stuff,
so we just capture it.
- We'd always spoken about wanting to do
another "Long Way."
- Charley's motorcycle accident
really was the catalyst
for getting us all back together again.
- Good luck, my good friend.
- You too, Charley, good luck.
I couldn't be happier than to be doing
another one with you.
It's great.
- Aw.
You know, we're sitting there,
"Well, what bike do we go on?"
And we sort of came up with this idea
of going electric.
- This is the first one.
- The first one, man.
- Think we just plug in?
Oh, it's going up.
Look, it's working, it's working.
Charley and I, we wanted to do this trip
on electric bikes because it's the future.
It's opened my mind up
to what is going on in the world.
Hello.
- Hello, mate.
- Harley is pushing into this new realm
of electric-powered motorcycles.
We rode prototype models.
You could see they completely
started again with the suspension.
How long will it take me
to break an indicator?
- It stalled?
- Ooh.
- An hour.
[laughter]
- Rolling!
- Three, two, one.
[music continues]
- Traveling electric, you have to
approach it in a slightly different way.
- The challenge is trying to get
the miles done
on a bike that really had a range
of just over 100 miles.
- We've run out of battery.
With 10 miles to go.
- The conditions had to be right.
Oh, man, it's ice.
As soon as it got colder,
we've got less miles.
- We hadn't really realized how much
the batteries are affected
by the cold.
[music stops]
Shut down again.
- Think it's the cold,
that's why it won't charge.
In some of these remote places,
we needed to have a bike that could
plug into a wall anywhere.
Boom.
I'm not sure whether
they're very good charges,
and I feel like probably they're not.
But if we didn't have
two separate circuits,
we couldn't really charge both bikes
at the same time.
Came on this big multi-country adventure
with a travel plight.
And that was tricky.
- 100%.
I'm happy about that.
And it was a real steep learning curve
to figure it out,
but once you put your helmet on
and you get going,
everything else washes away.
It's beautiful.
You start thinking about where you are.
- On the way to Machu Picchu.
Ooh.
[laughs]
I've always wanted to see it.
[whispers] Wow.
And I can't really believe we're here.
[indistinct chatter]
[music continues]
When you get out in the world,
you just find the kindness of people.
It makes you feel very nice
about humanity.
They gave us lunch,
and now we're siphoning their electricity
and eating their food.
Just so beautiful riding along
with Charley.
It's been amazing.
Amazing.
The nicest thing about it,
really, is to get
to spend that time
with your best friend.
You look good in that one, Charley.
- It changed both of our lives forever.
- We've crossed so much of the Earth
on our motorbikes together.
It made us very close.
[music concludes]